en este vídeo me gustaría pensar en las
distintas poblaciones que comparten un
mismo ecosistema y que pueden
interactuar entre ellas generando ciclos
que parecen estar relacionados entre sí
y existen muchos casos de esto pero el
ejemplo más citado es el caso en el que
una población se quiere comer a otra
entonces tenemos a la población
depredador el depredador que se quiere
comer a la presa presa así que ocurren
interacciones entre el depredador y la
presa lo pondré de este color porque es
lo que se come entonces pensemos en cómo
es que interactúan esas poblaciones
vamos a dibujar una gráfica por aquí tal
vez si estén familiarizados con esto
cuando mostramos cómo puede cambiar una
población con el tiempo miren el eje
horizontal corresponde al tiempo y el
eje vertical corresponde a la población
población entonces en nuestro punto
inicial supongamos que la presa empieza
en 1
punto relativamente alto supongamos que
en este momento en el tiempo se
encuentra ahí y vamos a suponer que por
cualquier otra razón la población
depredadora es relativamente baja
que creen que pasara bueno en este punto
con un número bajo de depredadores será
más fácil para ellos encontrar su cena y
les será más fácil atrapar a la presa
entonces como es más fácil para los
depredadores obtener su cena podemos
imaginar que su población empieza a
aumentar su población aumenta por lo que
la presa será atrapada con más
regularidad porque habrá más cazadores
así que esa población empieza a
disminuir hasta el punto en el que la
población de la presa es tan pequeña que
los depredadores empiezan a tener
problemas encontrando comida por lo que
ahora su población también empieza a
disminuir pero conforme disminuye esta
población qué pasa con la presa bueno
como ahora existen menos depredadores su
población empieza a aumentar entonces
creo que con éxito ya vieron lo que está
pasando el depredador y la presa tienen
esta interacción cíclica entre ellos y
lo que acabamos de dibujo
se conoce como ciclo depredador presa
ciclo depredador presa así que podemos
imaginar un mundo en el que existe un
ciclo entre poblaciones de depredadores
y de presas pero también podemos
utilizar simuladores computacionales que
muestran todo esto e incluso podemos
encontrar datos de observación en campo
que pueden mostrarnos esto uno de los
ejemplos más comunes son las
interacciones entre la liebre americana
que en este caso es la presa y el lince
canadiense que es el depredador en este
caso es el depredador y miren aquí
tenemos un ciclo muy parecido al que
dibujamos pero estos son datos reales
aquí podemos ver el paso del tiempo y
podemos ver que son largos periodos de
tiempo que van desde principios de 1800
hasta pasados los 1900 años así que aquí
se muestran los datos de cerca de 100
años y en el eje vertical tenemos a los
miles de animales
tan graficando tanto a la población de
liebres americanas como a la de linces
canadienses y como podemos ver cuando la
población de depredadores es alta es
decir cuando existen muchos linces
canadienses existe una población pequeña
de la presa es decir de liebres y como
en esta situación tenemos una población
pequeña de comida la población
depredadora empieza a disminuir voy a
dibujar una flecha la población de
depredadores disminuye y después
conforme la población depredadora
disminuye la población de empresas
aumenta porque ahora hay menos linces
cazando entonces la población de
empresas aumenta y también podemos ver
lo contrario cuando la población de
presas bueno estos son datos reales no
siempre se ve todo perfecto pero cuando
la población de empresas es muy alta y
la población de depredadores es
relativamente pequeña bueno los
depredadores dicen mira
ahora es muy fácil conseguir comida y
ese es como el punto inicial así que su
población empieza a aumentar y conforme
la población de depredadores aumenta
ahora la población de empresas disminuye
así que estos son datos reales que nos
muestran el ciclo depredador presa
durante muchas muchas décadas entre la
liebre americana que es la presa y el
lince canadiense que es el depredador